este repunte de contagio se debe en la
mayor parte de los países de europa a
insuficiente cobertura de vacunación y
la relajación prematura de las medidas
de protección y de restricción es una
doble vertiente que hay que analizar en
toda su complejidad los países con más
proporción de población vacunada como
españa y portugal tienen las incidencias
menores en europa pero también son
países que han mantenido al negocio de
la mascarilla del uso de las medidas de
protección y las restricciones y también
antes delante es la variante alfa era la
dominante en europa y ahora todos los
casos son de delta según el centro
europeo para la prevención y el control
de enfermedades
explíquenos por qué el cambio de la
prevalencia entre estas dos variantes
bueno esto es un fenómeno natural en la
evolución de cualquier infección viral
en los virus mutan se producen variantes
nuevas algunas de estas variantes son
más contagiosas así fue la variante
delta inicialmente y ahora con la
variante del tacto nos en europa y es
natural que vayan
sucediéndose los agentes infecciosos en
razón de su capacidad de infección y en
razón de su mayor violencia o contagios
chica entonces lo que tenemos que hacer
es simplemente limitar la incidencia en
europa y en otros países del mundo para
que tengamos menos variantes con el que
se generan por mutaciones y menos
probabilidad de que existen variantes
contagiosas de mayor grado o variantes
que escapen a la eficacia de las vacunas
usted habla de la importancia de limitar
la incidencia y también de controlar
estas variantes que estas variables
entonces qué medidas concretas se deben
adoptar para paliar los nuevos contagios
en estos momentos las medidas
fundamentales son aunar a la población
diana que es la población de más de 12
años que en su totalidad no a un 60 o 70
80 por ciento tenemos que vacunar al 100
por ciento de la población diana para
otorgarles protección individual y
además generar el suficiente
grado de protección global sin que
exista la inmunidad de nuevo porque no
la hay para luego mismo pero al mismo
tiempo tenemos esos dos procesos más
mantener las medidas de protección y
mascarilla a distancia física de nueva
numeración es mantener las restricciones
en las interacciones sociales
desprotegidas cuando tenemos altas
incidencias tanto ocio nocturno como
eventos masivos como actividades en
interiores más ventilados y tercero no
podemos bajar la guardia con respecto a
la detección recostó el rastreo la
realización de pruebas y la isla miente
de positivos sí señor lópez muchas
gracias por este completo reporte